comedy seller The Comedy Store and now
the mother ship out of those three clubs
what makes the comedy seller number one
in your opinion so funny man I've
performed I performed in all three clubs
in the last uh week so it's very funny
to see the you know to see the
difference in them and they're truly I
mean The Comedy Store is also one of my
favorite clubs on Earth um and it was my
first time at the mothership which is
truly an incredible experience I think
with the seller it's just like again man
they got four room
they 80 shows a week every when you sell
out every single show a week and it's
just and also like New York City Comedy
I mean that there's so much competition
there's so many other options for comedy
in that City that it's it really does
feel like it's kind of like the you know
there's a reason that Chappelle and rock
and Ray Romano and all the you know
these famous Comics are constantly going
there